[Music]
we have 3.7 million farmers and more
than 10 million fish ones all across
Indonesia
my dream was to operate my own fish
farms a thousand of fish farms I tried
to speak to many farmers back then and I
saw similar problems that the farmers
face in feet costs and from that
discussion impulsively it's just a
spontaneous idea that I preached on
Farmers hey what if I can build a
machine that you can feed your fish from
your phone and they were very excited
about it
[Applause]
my name is Ava I'm CEO and co-founder of
efficially
[Music]
our approach is really how we can help
small scale and small older Farmers
increase their productivity and provide
efficiency on their biggest costs which
is feeding so 70 to 90 of the total cost
and currently done manually by labor so
if they're managing 20 farms and they
have to fit the fish by themselves it
was really a hard job to do
so that's why we started on building
this official feeder so this is a
machine to fit the fish automatically it
is connected to the cloud and connected
to the sensor that can sense the fish
appetite so it can improve the feed
efficiency or defeat conversion ratio as
well as certainly increasing the growth
of the fish so they can shorten the
Harvest cycle
we already have 75 000 Farmers farmers
cooperatives and Farmers group and in
total we have close to 250 000 ponds all
across Indonesia and we're already 27
provinces all across Indonesia in in 350
cities
a soil entrepreneurship as a tools to
really change the livelihood of families
building the business is not about
creating your wealth for your own but
really building a community building the
impact for a bigger sector to more
people
so I think that's my first tips for the
entrepreneur I think if you would like
to be a tech founder really ask to
yourself whether this is what you really
want to build and why Find Your Way find
your reason and the reason is not really
about being a cool and being rich it
needs to be bigger reason than that that
you would like to Aspire to be
so for me personally measuring my own
success is on that on an impact level
because I want
to see myself at the end of my life to
contribute to solve world's anger's
problem